hi there welcome to the need to know a
weekly wrapup show of all the biggest
news from this week let's see if it's
weekly oh yeah yeah we're trying we're
trying it out we're gonna see what you
guys think about it
but you guys actually gave us the idea
for this whole you did forever ago
that's great hey who are we all Oh
kicking it off over here is your old pal
Sam you can find the ants and bash Sean
shorter I talk about all kinds of nerdy
things but who's this oh this is Eric
Foss hi I'm Erik Bosse tsunami
breakdowns a da bots on twitter and you
can just click to some other video
you'll probably have me hosting my name
is Phillip Malina thank you information
they need to know I'm Maude Garrett oh
that is a pretty cool shirt bite me soon
yeah you know did you see this
Eric only has three shirts - shirts - me
real quick this show is we're not just
gonna talk about the things that you
need to know about we definitely will
get into all of that and by watching the
show you will have the information you
need to know to get through your week of
news without having to watch or go
anywhere else also we're gonna give you
that new rock stars nugget of
information that we dove in and did some
research on just so you know even a
little bit more you can impress people
all parties but the other thing that
we're really excited about doing is
getting you guys into the show we're
starting to use this app called Stardust
to do that it's an app that's it's
almost kind of like a snapchat kind of
thing or something where you're posting
videos but you are only talking about
movies and TV shows in the nerdy stuff
so we care about we're a were on it you
can you can look us up on it but the way
that we are trying to incorporate it
here is that throughout our videos
throughout any snow episode you're gonna
see you guys
posts in that app we're gonna share that
and we're gonna be reacting to the stuff
that you're sending us in that app your
video will show up here on our channel
in our video so I think it's super
exciting because I'm gonna get to know
what you guys look like also and what
your bedrooms look like but then also
we'll be posting on there too which is
exciting
ya know yeah it's super easy to use it's
just video it's it's super authentic
like right when you get out of a movie
theme and just click the cord
would you like 30 seconds right 30
seconds but you would roll genuine
immediate reaction and it's kind of nice
that when you're sitting then you're
like I don't have a camera setup I don't
have a studio I don't have the
professional means to make video YouTube
content no this is about sharing your
fandom and being like I need to tell
someone about this particular thing and
in this show let me show you so many
trailers as well and when you see these
trailers for the first time you can jump
on to start us and be like well I think
this but you guys are doing the same
thing as well you're using the app
through new rock stars and you're
posting your behind-the-scenes reactions
yeah around the office yeah you can
actually find us at new rock stars I've
already posted a couple videos that kind
of go into my crazy theories and the
kind of weird in them and we'll see some
of it the fact that it's not the way we
make our youtube videos our YouTube
videos are highly researched and thought
out and edited and all that these are
like super raw and you see how weird we
are in the hallway and in the lunch room
we're real fans it's really cool it's a
it's a very authentic experience yeah so
we're just really excited to have you
guys start using it so you can send us
your reactions and then we'll put them
into the show so we can see a couple of
videos this episode but we didn't tell
you guys this yet so in the future it'll
be you guys this time it's gonna be some
of us and some other people that we
found yeah let's go ahead jump right
into our main topic guys we have some
breaking news this morning we have a new
trailer for first trailer for the New
Mutants guys the new mutants trailer
exactly what I've been preaching for and
asking for forever
people look at comic book movies and
superhero movies and they're like yeah
that's a genre no genre is horror genre
is drama genre is comedy not superhero
this is a superhero horror movie I'm so
excited
yeah this is a an adaptation of the New
Mutants from the Marvel x-men comics but
this it's gonna be a horror film
psychological horror film directed by
Josh Boone the guy did The Fault in Our
Stars right so it's tough to point out
there to him but it's also the writer
who did the father ourselves but the
writer who did Faulkner so this it's a
writing team they also did 500 days of
summer and they've done a couple of
different things and these guys I've
actually like kind of obsessed with them
because they have this really
interesting mode that they get into
that's the way I write to where they
hate themselves while they're writing
and they're very like like they beat but
it ends up with these like really raw
authentic characters which is why they
had them do Fault in Our Stars because
it's really true to being a teenager
that's why they're like these people
really get authentic teenage emotions
and New Mutants is all about the youth
the younger class and writing that
authentically is super interesting
thought that actually was brilliant
except for the horror things like oh
well that's gonna be weird yeah but it
also is a great well they made me cry in
all those movies so cry from horror and
it's being scared now or anything cuz
Sam cries a lot so this is obviously the
x-men universe but where does it fall
into oh yeah let's give some background
on who are the new mutants or what I've
been Indians they were originally
introduced 1982 as the younger students
kind of new class I have always existed
Hey there's pictures of me from the
Civil War this is kind of a new class
right of Charles Xavier school for
gifted youngsters but in this adaptation
this mental hospital is not Professor
X's school these are all mutant kids now
who are held against their will in this
terrifying Hospital you may recognize
some of these cast members include
Maisie Williams Arya Stark from Game of
Thrones yes girl but I have to knowing
that this is from 500 days of summer she
now the Manic Pixie dream girl I think
she's manic yes one of her MarySue
qualities if she's gonna fall in that
trope is she can shape-shift into a wolf
for more
you may also recognize anya taylor joy
from split them another good
psychologist she's great awesome she is
this is the casting on this is like
insanely great and she is honestly
killing it with the thrillers yeah this
is great
they've got a young actor from almost
every popular franchise yes Sam Guthrie
he's the oldest kid in the group who
plays a cannonball that's his comic
writer you can generate thermo chemical
energy and propel his body there's also
the main kid really is a Danielle
Moonstar played by a blue hunt I think
we have she is psycho the character was
later called Mirage comics you can
project illusions of her enemies
greatest fears and weaknesses one of her
first manifestations was a vision of a
demonic bear who killed her parents that
was a vision experience from losing her
parents that went missing on a hunting
trip and then she was able to see the
thing that she believed killed it what I
do when I'm watching horror movies I
picture the worst thing that could
happen
it usually doesn't happen but I'm
already too scared and Scott after you
see it know you're not gonna want what I
have to tell real quick also the yeah
she's she's Colossus his sister do you
believe in magic yeah but I think the
real thing that we're we all are super
excited about and what you guys are
probably pumped about is the horror yes
she's clearly the most excited about
that's what I was talking about him I
started as post where it's like everyone
talks about superhero in comic book
movies as a genre no
no those are characters that's not a
genre put characters in any genre and
you have you know a bank robbery and a
comedy is very different from bank
robbers in a drama this is the same
thing we're putting them into a horror
and I love that all right do you think
that the genre of superhero has become
uplifting saves the day you know hope
because that's all we've ever seen
before
mmm yeah no if there isn't there's
definitely like a trope I don't know yes
the tripod hope yeah the trope hope hope
trope hope so yeah I kind of like it's
maybe it something about the x-men
because there is there's like an army of
different characters and they all kind
of have their different feel to them
like like if you guys watch Legion on FX
that was another so it's kind of a
psychological horror and and within the
x-men universe and
hoorah there's like eight hours in that
day what are we actually but I feel like
Legion is is straight-up a direct
influence on this like even in the
yellow fabric that they're that they're
wearing it's like it's not spandex it's
just yellow color influence on like a
thick wall it's also very much has a lot
of Legion in it visually and both Legion
and it looks like this trailer seemed to
be borrowing some from Stanley Kubrick
with the shining like the the reveal of
what looks like the villain here
definitely looks like that creepy shot
from The Shining with the guy in the
mask doing something wait why is there
like literally a serial killer yeah I'll
get to that effect oh there's a like a
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest isn't it
with like the nurse ratchet who kind of
like his so manipulative and in control
but she's the one that is like the most
horrific thing out of the whole thing I
mean I'm also a video game player and
one of the games that I have played that
it's like okay everything about this is
nor is outlast and you start as a
journalist exploring an abandoned insane
asylum and now that this is in a mental
institution and everyone's held against
their will
I'm like oh has a no sound you also we
were talking earlier
in about house so we were wondering like
is it a good idea to jump Shana and I'm
very excited to jump Jonna and Eric was
reminded me that we very recently had
another superhero movie jump genre but
Logan right yeah that's what x-men needs
has been around for 10 goddamn no like
no longer right yeah when I'm ancient I
remember being around when the original
so ok I'm gonna get into real quick this
is our little new rock stars like deeper
point here that the things that we're
trying to see we're trying to put
together like what kind of horror movie
is this what exactly is going on there's
a guy in the mask but there's also the
frighteners kind of thing coming into
walls and whatnot so frighteners came
out of my birthday which again 19 years
old good point
well the villain of the story is known
as the demon bear and this is from the
comics but it to be clear like this is
the equivalent of like the purple man to
jessica jones and then the importance of
the ark is like the Dark Phoenix saga in
the x-men stories like this is the story
you tell when you do the New Mutants
story so I actually don't want to tell
you too much because it's a really short
target you could you could jump in and
read all the issues very quickly say I'm
not going to I'm still not gonna spoil
it for you but I'm gonna make you go
with us to go watch it and then we'll
put your reaction live on Stardust but
basically this is one of these creatures
that is kind of a shape-shifter can
teleport can jump around appears a bunch
of different things so like I love it
because its first like official
appearance it's a bear cloud
in this moment she's like he kills my
parents and then he like he pretty much
kills her she ends up in the hospital
for a lot of hosaka actually but it's
just like this cloud which is kind of
like what she creates was it mmm so okay
so here's the interesting thing is is it
real or not it's a big question of it
and it turns out there's definitely an
element of maybe you're feeling it by
believing and it kind of thing so to me
it was very similar to two penny wise
from it which is why I was wondering why
you might not even know who that is and
then it also might be of shadow king I
love that because not only is this kind
of like a shutter island' psychological
thriller this is so much scarier because
they put a monster in a mental
institution that thrives on your dark
thoughts how do you like that Simon okay
and also by the way the New Mutants if
you've ever cringed when you kind of
like oh it's like kids forever this is
the exact story where they kind of
realized when they were making the
comics they were like man our new me ins
things kind of like for babies it kind
of sucks so then they came up with this
exact story to be like this is the New
Mutants growing up so this is exactly
the version that I would want to see
you're gonna watch it I'm gonna I'm
gonna be there night one for movies
movies about time travel those I'm there
night one no matter what I'm excited for
it I think though some of the horror
elements get kind of taken out of it
like it kind of got it deflated itself a
little bit because you're like oh we
know what the element is that scary here
it's a person like you're like there's
no mystery really you're just kind of
trying to pick out who is doing this
righteous and shape-shifts yeah but you
if you know who's playing who then
you're just like oh that's the person
who's the threat so it kind of it kind
of kneecaps itself a little bit but I'm
still excited for it yeah I'll be
watching it I mean I feel like I've
blocked out some childhood memories from
being imprisoned in a mental institution
so maybe this will help trigger and
remember some things that I need to
process you were imprisoned as a child I
feel like at what
but again we're talking about like BC
right yeah look I feel like in this
world than the word the word mutant has
been said so many times you know when
you say the same word over and over
again it loses its meaning
I feel like mutant has been that so for
it to pivot with its genre I'm about
that it just so happens at the Jarah
that they've chosen I won't have
anything to do with I would love to see
that yeah exactly
but like with all horror things you
watch it and then you tell me about it
and that's enough for me really really
cool here because I want to do a trivia
question and this is not interesting
involving you guys and your knowledge
and what you know but it's you as well
so as you know fimo and I were on
Westeros weekly and now that's wrapped I
want an excuse to talk about Game of
Thrones still bloodshed here so our
question that we're going to pose to you
is how many total deaths did we see
there's this character screen deaths did
we see on Game of Thrones
not in just the last season that we had
the entire game of Thrones Season 1 to
see if the season 7 how many people do
you think died now that's a huge thing
to say so yeah little bit of specifics
we're gonna count all major characters
that have died which is already like 400
supporting characters and background
extras White Walkers on extras good I've
been counting does my favorite we're
gonna do White Walkers whites as well
dire wolves
dragons even more yeah we're also
actually there's a good thing to bring
up the dragon because we're also going
to count those who had have died but do
come back to life and we are going to
include the characters that technically
died off-screen but their bodies showed
up after so there's oh there's body I
think literally everyone in the world
times where someone casually off-screen
mentions all that's right the Battle of
this where this meant amount of people
died that's not going to be counted okay
it has to be directly affiliated with
the show yes even if they died off
screen but we know that they're dead
because we see them later that does
count when you do see sweeping shots oh
[ __ ] you guys yeah you keeping track of
this - dude math the number of faces
[Laughter]
fresh in my mind I kind of have sure in
westeros weekly we actually didn't count
yeah episode but that's just one out of
seven seasons all right what's our time
limit will actually come back with the
correct answer because there is an
answer that we have I don't even know it
but there is a correct current guess is
right now how much time do you think oh
okay okay one two three five six seven
going on I will say a thousand a
thousand will be my guess but you said
background extras including background
extras yeah I think there's on white
yeah I'm gonna say 10,000 okay
10050 your closest yeah either way I
think places what if it's ten thousand
and twenty five then you both win yeah
all right have to go on kill someone
else right yeah yeah I'm actually gonna
say 3,700 you don't know the number I
have no idea oh man yeah you know the
number
now go count three thousand seven
hundred and seventy thirty seven seventy
a year that America gets remade there
has to be some sort of stakes here a
quarter wins I'm gonna say gets to close
out the show because we're doing a
little sign offs but you get to do it on
behalf of everyone and say whatever you
want to
at them cannot be offended the loser has
to drink the rest of my water and if
it's you quick sidenote
quick side note to the audience really
quick one of the reasons we've actually
scheduled to do this show a different
day and Maude was sick and couldn't make
it she had bronchitis for a long time
just getting over now these are real
stakes here on the need to know I
believe the original stakes was wearing
a bucket on your head but sure will go
away fine oh yeah I got it I know I've
watched it I know I feel confident all
right all right let's move on and we'll
deal with that later
this is gonna be a disaster at the end
of the show here guess the other huge
huge biggest thing that happened this
week obviously was a poor biting my head
is the last Jedi trailer the second
major one so this trailer like blew
everyone away but also blew away the
last trailers even though the movies
like already gonna come out this one for
some reason like people are like hi
watched it though I actually had to do a
poll on my Twitter saying he wants to
avoid everything because right this is
the thing it was definitely interpreted
that way but what he meant was if you
don't want to know anything else and you
want to go into the movie blind then
don't watch it which is like obvious
common sense right but then everyone
said we can't watch the trailer now he
told us not to watch the trailer then
changes his mind saying like oh I
changed my mind I watch it watch it
watch it which feels like Kathleen
Kennedy had a gun to his head
she has both powers she's got her
lightning fingertips ready yeah so we're
gonna assume you did watch it not only
did you hopefully watch you also
probably watched our breakdown of it
right
Eric went through and tore it apart into
every little piece that he could I found
a lot of like real cool stuff but it is
again like you know a choice you have to
make is this is this giving away too
much for some people though it wasn't
that we looked too closely it was giving
away too much they're getting these
vibes from the movie now based on this
trailer that this movie's gonna be a
repeat of Empire Strikes Back yeah well
when you have a trilogy which has been
around for decades and it was the most
successful version of star wars that
we've seen to date
we noticed that with force awakens whole
what do you know they're building a
giant duster called the star killer base
and it's just like wait we have seen
this before so the natural assumption is
well we've seen Rey's she's got she's
unleashing her Jedi powers at the moment
she's getting a trainer this is a rocky
episode where it's the whole movies a
montage of like you know being better
and then of course we'll see the end of
everything where it's not the enemy that
we thought it was kylo Ren it'll be
Snoke who is this entity like the
Emperor you know yeah it's a sauce salt
covering a red soil base which are like
I want those on my Lisa binder everyone
on my timeline feed actually it's not
ice because it's crystallized
it's crystal so you're insulting the
people it looks like an evolved Pokemon
like an ice one good because I get to do
it to you guys that's a snack for
Chewbacca and he's gonna but okay so
here's a question cuz I actually don't
want to debate too much the details of
what exactly is gonna be in this movie
cuz I was watching your star dust post
about yeah which actually show that real
quick yeah hi guys so I just rewatched
the last Jedi trailer probably like five
times back-to-back and the more I think
about it I really think we are being
sled I think Disney deceived us with
this trailer I went back to rewatch
rogue one and I realized that most of
the footage that I remember lovely and
from that trailer wasn't in the final
cut of the film I think that's exactly
what they're doing with the last Jedi
I think characters we think are talking
to other characters are talking to them
and I think it's gonna be a whole new
movie when we watch it so you think that
the trailers misleading us and it's
totally not the story that's coming up
and also you're really weird in the
hallway yeah I was I was really loud the
camera cut off when people kind of poke
their head out the door like is this guy
they just gave me their tinfoil and I
just started making a hat yeah well they
had no yeah okay so here here's my kind
of thought I know it sound a little bit
like a conspiracy theorist but like look
we've been breaking down trailers on
this channel for a while and didn't we
that's what we do it's kind of our bread
and butter we look closely but I think
this trailer was edited intentionally to
be deceptive I think there are lots
where voiceover is happening over like
other characters that we think Snoke is
talking hello but it's done yeah you're
right it's been done before like on when
we start with rogue one it ended that
first trailer ended when we thought with
us thinking that gen or so was gonna
switch to the dark side and then half of
that trailer footage wasn't even in the
final cut of the movie and I think
that's just what Disney's doing if they
have the budget to over shoot stuff and
shoot stuff specifically for the trailer
and then this movie half of this gonna
be on the cutting room floor distrust
mistrust and so it's like well we don't
even know what you're gonna do Disney
because you keep playing with ours or
this is just like part of a narrative
they want us to get Mithila once they
get excited so they're intentionally
cutting this trailer to make it feel
like it's gonna be an Empire Strikes
Back thing because we they know that we
all love that film not like they really
need an excuse to kiss in the theater I
already bought my ticket but like I
think when we go see this movie there's
gonna be a surprisingly different
narrative these final two shots when it
looks like Kyle is reaching out to Ray
as you watching the breakdown I point
out those are from completely different
right right it's yeah it's a price
so I think we're all gonna be very
surprised by what movie wind-up scene
it's gonna feel very different I think
so I wouldn't remember announce what's a
pro in a con that you heard from the
trailer poor egg is good con is that I
was
I fell asleep both times I watched force
awakens I know I've seen the whole thing
I just fell asleep with different parts
just don't make me fall asleep I mean
like that's the con don't make me regret
bringing you for me my pro was the new
music what John was doing with that kind
of like deconstructed Imperial March was
harmer thing and I was like this is what
I'm about and then usually don't listen
to the music
I'm usually that's not the first thing I
noticed and it wasn't this one my con is
good lord I can't stand out him driver
I'm not even a little bit not even and
every time I watch the force awakens
when he removes his helmet the cinema
laughed like there was a roar
they all laughed for that reason did you
say that when he removed his helmet oh
[Music]
no I actually thought of it when I sold
this trailer again and I set out that
and all of my male roommates went that's
really uncalled for
[Laughter]
no I really don't like this him as I
know his character is supposed to be
disgruntled and you know he's really
powerful he's trying to tune it so bro
it's pretty yeah take on it yeah well so
my thing is that I really enjoy about it
is like whether or not it's gonna be
like Empire or not I'm probably a force
awakens apologist about like oh it's it
that was really similar to
to any hope and it's like my thing is
still yeah
they did that by design to reintroduce
us into the Star Wars well they did a
lot of great things by doing that if we
get stuff that's similar to Empire
Strikes Back the best Star Wars movies
to win I'm fine with that I want and
here's the real reason why not just
because it's the best Star Wars movie
but because it's the one with the
darkest themes and it begins that path
into into the darkness honestly which is
of the most interesting element of the
whole thing any good story about a hero
is not only about the time that he's
succeeding but it's a challenge and he's
the most scared and he goes to his
lowest low oshi that is what's gonna
happen for her I think here we're gonna
see the almost the reverse of the
MarySue element you know like people are
like oh but it's such a cutie like she's
gonna try and put up and it's like it
doesn't look like she's gonna try it
that well here and I'm very excited to
see the realistic take on that yeah and
I'm noticing the NuForce power
especially with the dark side is just
legit torture hey I'm gonna look you up
literally make you scream from the
inside yeah let's move on to our by the
numbers segment that's related to this
Star Wars thing I don't think I saw this
going around this week but there is a
chart that we saw that lists all the
different planets that are in different
Star Wars movies which movies have the
the most planets at slash locations and
we find that topping the chart is
Revenge of the Sith by mister Fah
oh yeah with so that's why that movie so
good it's okay they're jumping around
planet to planet we don't get a sense of
I think a lot of it honestly is from
this order 66 montage right before Wars
we saw like 10 different planets right
in that in that two minutes seconds
broke one right which I wouldn't really
think as well the force awakens the we
see six planets but I don't if you see
this red stripe section here there were
three new planets at it there why is
that
well that's because with short when
George Lucas recut the end of Return of
the Jedi
he added those shots of Khorasan and
that
investment of showing people celebrating
soda payment on which version they were
going off of because he wanted to show
the entire galaxy celebrating the this
game-changer battle I guess so what's
our what's our real question here does
this help the movies do we need planet
hop I mean it's Star Wars right so it's
like you need some amount of planet
hopping but is okay so is it how much
about you caring about a Star Wars film
is you caring about seeing different new
planets just a little bit I mean I love
universe building that's one of the
coolest parts for me watching because as
a kid I was like as fun as it is to like
learn the story of the original not the
original excuse me episodes one through
three as a kid I had fun watching them I
know they're bad now but I loved when
they'd go to like the world where it's
always raining and you meet the clones
that world with Jar Jar as a kid I'm
like yeah I liked I liked the underwater
aspect of it but it's not the most
important part for me yeah if you look
at like I don't know for me a new hope
and we're in Empire Strikes Back are the
two best films and there's a fewest
number of locations there it's like yeah
you can go deeper in any one location
like I feel like half of the movie of a
new hope was spent on the Death Star and
half of it was on Tatooine I really got
to know those locations yeah and I got
to know the characters by seeing them in
those locations so that's what I feel
the same way with like Tatooine like
when you know Mos Eisley cantina and
with one line you know scum and villainy
it's like a scented right there you're
like this is cool knowing that Jabba is
there and Jabba basically ran the
underground crime like he was a crime
the mommy and I went to Wales like no
I'm thinking a book I'm thinking a Peter
Pan but what I think that the more you
know about a planet and the history
there the more you have to associate
with it and I felt a little bit not
betrayed but you know when the force
awakens first came out and we see this
desert planet were like oh we're back at
Tatooine and it's like no it's jakku I'm
like what how what is this is this the
same thing but different and then it's
like oh no no there was a huge battle
there and all this took place I'm like
well it did now but it didn't before
so they're adding in all these things
but no kata Cannon and it's like man you
like wrong you like going to what they
already had dive deeper rather than just
definitely like making it my point
concise no no no I'm trying to get on
the same page they disagree it's now
that you put it that way now I'm
understanding my opinion better which is
that I think some of the movies should
be adding and some of the movie should
be diving deeper and I think that's a
great reason for like kind of the ant
ology that's happening on the side where
if it's main saga it's like okay these
are universal level or galaxy level at
least movies are going to introduce us
to new worlds even the prequel is doing
that you know they're introducing us to
these new places
but then on a side story I would love
like a bottle movie a bottle episode or
something kind of like what's the recent
John Goodman movie the Cloverfield Lane
it's a whole movie that mostly takes
place downstairs and upstairs right
right and it's like imagine that movie
was somehow in the Star Wars universe or
something like and you're trying to you
know you'd you against a bounty hunter
the whole time or something you're
trying to protect your whole family yeah
my favorite episode of Firefly the Joss
Whedon series is the out of gas episode
which is a great sci-fi bottle episode
of just like what happens when the
characters just on a ship and it can't
fly through space and I feel like I
would love to see a Star Wars equivalent
of that like what happens where it's
just someone kind of with a couple other
people trying to get that in this movie
though right like on the little island
with Luke and you learn
sure I guess I'm saying like there's the
moment you can leave the story now you
like it's not as hard to do so they
don't have to make it as amazing but
usually a bottle episode of TV shows who
they're trying to save money so they
have to set it in one location with the
exact same characters and they can shoot
it all in like one or two days and so
they have to make that so good I just
thought about this I really dislike in
sci-fi movies especially space
adventures when you they go to a planet
they're like here on the planet
everyone's a monk and everyone believes
the same religion and that's it like
once you visit this one city you
basically don't know the recipe works
like yeah no that's not how planet is
and it should have a very diverse
population so actually I would like if
it was more took place in one place I
want to learn more about it yeah they'll
land if aliens land and like Alaska no
one expects you to be an expert on
America geography you know we're all
experts on a sailing geography ask us
anything well it's a question about the
game well they have speaking of Star
Wars it's my turn to talk about
something I love Hulk's future he's got
a great new haircut gotta say I'm
excited for Thor Ragnarok but there's a
big story this week along with the
premiere of Thor Ragnarok and what Mark
Ruffalo accidentally streaming the movie
but there's a plan apparently that Mark
Ruffalo is been talking with Kevin Feige
and they have the they have a plan for a
trilogy for the Hulk hidden in other MCU
movies that he's gonna star in so like
34 one yeah you know bring in the big
box set of other movies but uh my
question for you guys is do you think
the Hulk deserves his own movie again
because their dad - or how my keeping
his story more confined be better for
this character cuz yeah so I haven't
seen Phil Ragnarok but I have seen a lot
of people's opinions about them
and they are now saying that this guy is
their favorite Avenger whatever happened
so I don't think that he was likeable
before because he wasn't given much of a
chance and back when the movies happened
what 14 and 12 or so don't 14 and there
you go when you had Bruce Eric Bana
yeah obviously they flopped at the
movies and it was like hey this is
giving superheroes a chance but that was
before Marvel figured out how to do a
very clever and successful formulaic
movie and so now I think with the
success of all the Avengers and it's
like cool we've got our very own Thor
franchise and Iron Man franchise and
hope hey home gonna tack onto another
one and then we'll see yeah I think
there's something about the character of
Hulk that like makes them more of a fun
like party crasher character rather than
one who you're gonna follow as a solo
film maybe that was obstructive semen a
team would be really good it's really
funny to see how they like especially I
like the hope they're going with in this
movie where he can talk like that's far
more interesting because it's not just
your emotion it's like Jekyll and Hyde
it's your coming-out so how else could
they explore an arc most of the time on
the screen the guy can't communicate
like anything yes
so a quick new rock stars nugget for you
to drop at a party the reason why they
have to do this I wish it was like a
great reason like the Hulk is best told
in these small chunks or whatever like
or in complimenting someone else's story
it's just a rights issue
it's that Marvel does not have the
distribution rights for an individual
Hulk movie so that's why I was always so
confusing about if the Edward Norton
Hulk movie it was part of the Marvel
Universe which it is actually Tony Stark
shows up in multiple characters now but
it's still a partnership with Universal
to do I'm almost like we don't need to
do partnerships with Universal so they
won't do it unless they get the full
rights of being able to do it so they
can sneak in a movie inside of Marvel
movies as long as they're not
distributing a standalone
movie annoying and you've heard me say
it before I hate rights issues a way to
handle it yeah yeah like a lot of comic
book companies do the same thing like
Caitlin snow killer frost on the flash
there's like this whole rights issue the
guy who create the original character
there's nine different iterations of the
killer frost and he gets zero money yeah
and he's so pissed he's like you're
she's in a TV show now I see nothing
from it so it's interesting like that
they are very sneaky I think it's a good
idea because the Hulk I've liked the
most is Avengers and I'm gonna like him
in Thor because I'm actually excited for
a Thor movie which is crazy so good good
for you I'm excited I don't know who
you're gonna pair him with now like next
it would be cool if like I don't man
because they're going through the same
thing with what the rights issues in
yeah I was thinking if you had Fantastic
Four and then you could do like a thing
and a Hulk
yeah like team-up like a big strong like
when the rock and Mark Wahlberg did that
movie where they're both just two Jack
guys robbing a bank I said if you
high-five will it caused a seismic flaw
Mark Wahlberg seems like a gem real
quick speaking people personality
disorder buy it to the Hulk real quick
I love what the Hulk's core thing is
it's a split personality disorder really
yeah and I feel like that's my wife it's
a bummer that could be a hell of a good
movie done right just one guy who's when
he goes dark you can see it and it ruins
a whole freaking town but also the
people that he loves have to be scared
of him I think that could be great but
they have to kind of split it up the
only thing that I think they do benefit
from is a Hulk standalone movie has
nothing nothing that can collide against
him that is anywhere close to him they
have to put them with like abomination
or whatever it's always annoying cuz now
it's not are not worthy so at least you
know you put them with or you put them
with other Avengers it's like people
that can withstand a Hulk story and you
can take it unless you have a
psychological in the head thing as well
that can control him what do you mean
well if someone can get any sight and
control his mind then the hell yeah I
know that
a great idea because then he's still
even further his own billing hmm yeah oh
I do like in the comic sometimes they
separate them Boehner and all right and
that way Boehner has to figure out how
to take out the Hulk but really it
becomes them having to sit down and talk
with each other because they're the same
person he's the embodiment of him being
abused as a child and then like banner
is the one repressing it and so he's
like no you actually need to address
this that's the only way see ya
but again but I mean do you not have a
lot of punching there's a lot talking
yeah there's a Superman we split him
Clark Kent Superman I want to bring up
real quick
because it was what it was a really good
trailer I thought yeah but I feel like
trailers are often be played in us now
you just went well somewhere described
it as Sam I told you you're welcome to
but but hang on to my point for one
second I think that we feel good about a
trailer when they really nail it with a
song choice they got yeah and that's
kind of what I was about to say about it
works like it's not new necessarily it's
just a you say they use David Bowie's
heroes and that kind of just like man
does it makes me have feelings and it's
a short and it's a cheat but it works so
often yeah I ate that up by the way if
you want to look it up it's gangs of
youth they did that cover about hero
song because I immediately download
amazing but going sorry yeah so so I
actually thought it'd be interesting to
do a we're gonna try here it's called a
by comparison segment might come up with
different names in the future based on
what you guys decide but by comparison
that sounds fun
so yeah it's exactly what's about to
happen we I just want to talk about
memorable song choices that were sampled
in other movie trailers and then see how
they kind of like were they accurate to
what that movie ended up being how did
they affect how you thought that movie
would be so for instance like a famous
example is the Bohemian Rhapsody usage
in Suicide Squad
when a movie actually was sources that
also you know bring up any other one
that you yeah the one that comes to mind
for me is in Logan the cover of Nine
Inch Nails hurt by Johnny Cash members
that I called that
did you call they're gonna use it way
back on that alternate universe called
source or said nerd we've heard that
they were gonna be doing Logan mmm-hmm
and then I it's in a video somewhere and
I'm like here's my pitch I think you you
do it maybe in black and white would say
end up doing if I come I release and I
was like somehow get Johnny Cash's hurt
[Music]
if you can't find it to say you know I'm
still there i but they also use way down
we go and I think it's Cali oh that's
capture how dark that movie was and so
so that movie you're saying nailed a
song choice that you were getting a
glimpse at the feelings you organ yeah
okay and so was your question is this
like a cheat or just the good it good
it's kind of like let's look at a couple
and see like okay is this something that
is being used to cheat a manipulate us
or is it something that actually is
doing a good job of giving a sneak peek
at our emotional state when we want
right our movies manipulative anyways
like that's the point but here's the I
mean I'll give it right there again with
the human Rhapsody we all fell in love
with Suicide Squad on that trailer but
not the one before it and then the
amount that we fell in love with that is
what changed that movie so crazily were
they I mean
people probably know the story but if
you don't the Bohemian Rhapsody edit on
that trailer was done by a trailer house
they timed it to the songs yeah and then
with the bulletin and everybody yeah
everybody loved that and we loved it too
and the reaction was so strong that the
that Warner's realized that's not our
movie though we just got this really
wrong we and we made people feel this
way our movie is not that so they asked
the trailer house to recut the movie and
make a new version of suicides because
the trailer was so good cause the
trailer was why there's 90 being song
excuse me for cursing but 90 songs in
the
first ten minutes of the movie everybody
has three three theme songs you're like
yeah I think it's really good win
whoever cuts a trailer usually they have
a post-production house outside of the
film's creative team who does it but if
they can work in conjunction with the
director like I believe David Fincher
had a lot of say in the kind of the
trailer for the social network which
with the Trent Reznor with the Trent
Reznor but the song that was used in the
trailer was that cover of Crete by
Radiohead that was just amazing that
trailer felt like its own short film
then almost right like it was exactly
social anxiety of having to like put
your entire digital presence online and
have that be who you are now a cover
that was more representative was also
that like chorus dark creepy thing but
that all these young people are doing
together yeah so if it comes out of the
themes of the movie and is able to make
a statement about what kind of film this
is that's actually accurate and not
deceptive then it could be really great
yeah yeah they definitely want you to
feel like no guys like they're not like
punching each other and you know like
calling each other names like they're
actually having a great time and look
they're saving the world the same time
yeah it's gonna pay off but hey the
trailer guy yeah because I also want
them to punch each other yeah like the
Iron Man he's Iron Man yeah that's what
the song is saying and that's what the
end their pain yeah I like that the
point of the trailer though is to get
bums in seats for the cinema so if they
are going to say hey we're gonna use
this particular song because this song
in itself has a history and it's gonna
connect with you in a way that maybe our
movie warrant but it's going to add
another layer to it social networks a
great example it's like the songs been
around for so long
everyone knows the song but then when
pairing it in a new kind of way it
provides a different tone everyone's
it's like well not only am i seeing that
what's happening in the trailer but I'm
feeling it and it's invoking 20 you know
years of hearing this particular song
yeah I'm not mad at it and it's that
same sort of same sort of thing you know
like with going back to why I'm fighting
for Star Wars to stick with the
that we know it's like we already have
the history there and then you apply the
history to new characters same thing
with this trailer the history of the
song then adds to what you're seeing in
the trailer yeah I think that's a that's
a great point as long as they honor that
when your butt is in the seat all right
once you go there if you're like this is
not what I feel like the 20 years record
I brought into this see I got I say you
know what gosh suicide score was a bad
movie but they did such a good trailer
good on them
really yeah Man of Steel had one of the
best trailers of all times X night or
knows how to cut those yeah an amazing
trailer but then also some do your time
about experiences well actually like
fantasy a lot but you're talking about
experiences where people feel
disappointed at the end of the movie and
they can't put their finger on it and
it's like you felt something before you
saw this movie that you did not end up
feeling watched I just wanna shout out I
think it was the first justice trailer
that used white stripes
Akito good was immediately I just wanted
to rock and it was like cool I care this
next trailer though and speaking of
trailer music we point this out earlier
and also in the breakdown I kind of dug
into this the force or the last Jedi
trailer uses some awesome music choices
that did reference things that we had
memories from past films using John
Williams score from the force awakens
using a mix of like kylos theme and the
Jedi steps music from the end of that
movie but also like mixing in a subtle
Imperial March homage in there so like
yeah using music that specifically links
back to some memory some nostalgia can
be really effective that's it that's
fascinating that Star Wars culturally
the score of that there's no words
the score of that is so raw theme that
we hear in pale March and we're like oh
no the bad guys are gonna close yeah
like we know exactly what these things
mean yeah and that's what all everyone's
trying to do with these trailers is like
oh there's gonna be some fun in this
movie oh no there's gonna be a dark part
he's gonna hurt himself today
it's just Internet Star Wars has done
that so effective may I have another
little segment if I might if I may we're
gonna try out a new thing called pitch
me so we're gonna move on to talk about
stranger things for a second hitch don't
worry cuz they call me that but treat
your things
dropped it's about to air in two weeks
so they dropped a final hopefully
trailer there's no need to make any more
and one of the theories we had while
watching the trailer is that they like
to use a lot of pop-culture references
from the time to kind of help the story
move along like the boys - yeah why and
I read somewhere they are actively like
they have a list of references that
they're there let's make sure to put
these in season dragons I'm about you
guys we need cleaner for boys who am a
mutant of playing Dungeons and Dragons
and that will use his fireball as a
wizard I was playing D&D and I heard it
was a character that was using five volt
that is 66 damaged guys hey Oh a magic
but they actually did that in the series
yeah well that's how they solved the
problem basically we really fun and this
first trailer that you know you got your
Ghostbusters trap to trap something I
don't know we'll see how that works out
but in the newest trailer we see a
slingshot like who's using Lucas Lucas
was yeah yeah and he used it last season
as well which is of course a reference
to Beverly from the original hit yeah
yeah the shards reference to when
Beverly used it to shoot a chunk of
silver a penny wise which is really
great yeah that's the whole sequence in
the new it movie they didn't use his
exact sequence but this is the one that
stuck with me as a kid because there was
little kids defeating a monster but
using their imagination of the same
Dennis the Menace toy yeah I'm not
kidding I bought that kind of slingshot
after seeing it and you killed so many
clams just like I you cut me buying it
and then me with a knife but okay so the
segment for pitch meme I'm curious what
do you guys think are good what other
popular games or toys from that era do
you think are gonna be weaponized that's
important so out of that era obviously I
know that era
grew up in it clearly let me tell you
about no but what do you guys think cuz
I know their ego was a big thing last
season now they have an ego game that's
coming out amazing what do you guys
think I would like I'll pitch you I want
to see a character use this Stretch
Armstrong to like stringing someone by
the neck
I don't know okay I won't say as a
weapon for them to use but I would love
for somehow Oh a perfect way to do
actually 11 to creat the hell out of
everyone by using okay I don't if you
guys know this in the 80s dolls were way
cooler than they are now and dolls were
animatronic they could walk on their own
and like Teddy Ruxpin also talking like
move and so I had my sister had but I
played with it this like like three foot
tall little girl and she just could be a
cog me I shall walk towards you I would
love to see just that little creepy
you went somewhere walking dolls now
I've seen everything
basically a robot not a robot yeah I
want to see a little kid baby robot you
couldn't say c-3po and keep it in a nice
fun baby doll think of c-3po if c-3po is
the inner skeleton and his skin has been
peeled off he's wearing a dress Rome and
it just disappears and it's gone so I
mean in the marbles kind of like you
have to chew and get the marbles but
yeah this thing's just like I don't know
how you have it but I mean like you know
Ghostbusters I have a stream and you
can't cross they just wanted to be like
we're all groomed you're eating eyeballs
yeah just something don't poof but like
I like the fact that whatever did eats
disappears forever
is good is gone this is a whole new
series like it oh they're hungry
but how huh I don't want this but it's
all I can think of so rich man what is
it not soccer boppers but Rock'em
Sock'em we're gonna get a reference to
that they're gonna be playing it earlier
and then like one like super beefy Oh
Sean Sean Astin's gonna do it he's just
gonna like uppercut a demon or some [ __ ]
I don't know but like it's gonna get
some kind of reference like that or I'd
want that to be clear like we would kind
of explain it but we where we sound like
crazy people right now but the reason
we're thinking of this is if you go back
and watch season one watch it again with
the I on the way they're using the toys
in the way they're making the references
then later in the season those things
keep coming back by the way they're not
just like we're like what if toys came
to life yeah what toys did you like that
do you think could be fun as weaponized
and so I'm going with Rock'em Sock'em
yeah yeah well let's actually take a
look at what videos we have in the
pipeline for next week on new rock stars
because we don't want to have to just
keep surprising you those videos are
making we can look forward to so we were
talking about stranger things we're
gonna have a new trailer breakdown for
stranger things nice what else do we
have in the pipeline uh we well you've
been doing this great thing where I mean
this was everybody everyone and their
mother that is subscribed to my mother
yeah your mother subscribe to new rock
they wanted to see Game of Thrones
breakdown so I mean and so we're trying
it out as best as we can there you guys
know how much work the Game of Thrones
breakdowns are so it's a it's a little
hard but we are trying to stick to it
what episode are you on right now ever
so - it's it's of this series yes season
1 episode 2 the kingsroad that's a sad
departure of the direwolf lady if you
remember but also the episode where
Joffrey gets like slapped and BS so
there's a lot of satisfaction but
there's a lot of interesting like subtle
foreshadowing that they end up doing
especially what him
the mystery of who is Jon Snow's mother
Sean Bean knows some stuff way before I
feel like even george RR martin did so
it's interesting to really watch this
episode yeah also I mean we watch the
series along with us yes yeah you have a
video I do I did a first breakdown of
the flash season 4 episode 1 which you
can check out right now but also I'm
gonna do an episode 2 I've been looking
for all those Easter eggs they got a
bunch of fun characters coming out and I
already think I have a pretty clear path
of how the seasons gonna break down
because they're literally copying one of
the most popular fighter things no it's
it's jet when geoff johns wrote for
wally was it's the truly favorite it's
the same so guys check it out it's
really fun cool and then we also have a
black panther trailer breakdown what
else you need to know you'll find out
next week when we do this same thing
again it's really one of the things i'm
most excited about is that you guys are
now going to be sending us and tagging
us at new rock stars on stardust to be
in these videos and then we're gonna be
reacting directly to what you guys are
talking about 30 seconds and all you're
doing is just giving you an actual raw
genuine reaction to the things that
we've been talking about anyway so you
can unleash yourself and the tag it
upload it and boom you can be on the
show
oh and like throw in I mean give us your
reactions because we'll be posting those
but also flat-out ask us questions in
your in your video and won't answer your
questions here on screen just make sure
to do at new rock stars as the text on
the video and that's how you link to us
also it'll be a link in the description
of like how to get it and how to follow
us on there so you can see our BTS style
creepy content of the way we are when
we're not in the studio just follow us
on there at Sam banner at fimo and new
rock stars and like share your reactions
to us immediately and we'll also be
interacting with you in the app to mod
what is the answer to the trivia
question I can't say yeah you may have
noticed a little while ago I asked you
all of you guys how many deaths have
occurred on Game of Thrones season one
through to Season seven there were
parameters with it but obviously the
numbers huge
10050 no mine was closer to users ten
thousand fifteen
a thousand motive as mine was 3,770 the
real answer is 2019 Wow which is two
years time so 2019 technically that
makes 17 talk to us anyway you want and
describe us in any manner and we know
the rules Bob Bob Barker show is whoever
gets lowers loser right not the guy who
goes over real quick as we're wrapping
up in your building up the courage this
we're gonna give everybody 30 seconds
just give a 30-second shout-out to
anything that you think is real cool
that you want to talk about yeah I will
hey shoutout video games overwatch
they've bumped up a few new characters
not new characters but characters traits
and I am now I'm happy to announce I'm a
mercy main which means heroes never die
on my watch
hey you don't understand any of it but
it's pretty cool huh are you thinking
about sucking on your spirits parched I
am I would like to talk about a TV show
that you guys need to watch it's on
Netflix so you guys are much tinier
things you can watch this right before
American vandal it stars Jimmy J Johnny
he created it be like true crime and
dick jokes you're gonna love this it's
amazing it's seriously like it the first
time so it's surprisingly good you think
it's like oh it's just gonna be frat
humor but then when it gets the episode
two you're like oh [ __ ] this might be
dealing with real serious problems in
society go check it out it's really yeah
my 30 seconds there's another comedy
show I love American vandal but I'm
really digging the new season of Nathan
for you and Comedy Central oh this is
like if you haven't seen you gotta check
the show anything fielder is this really
soft-spoken Canadian comedian who's
super funny but he doesn't like people
can help your business but he comes up
with these crazy roundabout ways to to
help your business that seem completely
self-defeating
it's extremely funny and really it just
deals with his like personal awkward
connections with people yes
yeah and then my thing I'm actually
crazy excited about you guys I didn't
hear a lot more about this in the future
we're starting to do merch and guys like
one of the main reasons that we delay
doing merch is because I've never liked
when I see a channels merch and it's
just like that's only your logo and
that's it or it's only something really
boring we instead like worked really
hard and we got really awesome designs
that we like like I've been going back
and forth on I can give you a sneak peek
hopefully right here these are closed
and I would actually want to wear and
that's what our merch is gonna be like
and also if you have ideas for clothes
like that that you want us to make or
like just let us know in the comments
and we will try to make them for you I'm
so excited
Plus ad pocalypse actually is starting
to hurt so the merch could help so much
but that covers us Eric what do you do
our goodbyes this happens yeah you drink
my drink my water Oh yum yum yum all
right everyone okay this concludes our
very first episode of the need to know
and once again we just want to encourage
you to go check out Stardust looking at
our link below in the description as you
try to grossed out here okay okay um
remember please like and share this
video subscribe to new rockstars and let
us know your thoughts on this format Oh
what kind of segments do do you like
what kind of topics do you want to see
us cover more and uh yeah using my
victory lap here big thanks to our host
of lipoma MIMO
man go help me I stink up my period Oh
like what okay uh I'm just being like
you got me mad
no one's inviting you to their bask not
great is it yeah and I think there was a
curse word and as to why people want to
buy you to their back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]